après l'Europe c'est au tour des
États-Unis de subir une nouvelle vague
de covid-19 si certains sont plus
touchés que d'autres l'enfant du pays et
aujourd'hui concerné par cette eau
décontamination les précisions avec
notre correspondant à Washington Thomas
bonnet
l'illustration de la détérioration de la
situation sanitaire aux États-Unis ce
sont ses membres de la garde nationale
qui ont tpb ployer en soutien au
personnel hospitalier dans certains
états du pays notamment l'Indiana ou
encore l'État de New York est-ce que
j'étais à fond face à une augmentation
particulièrement fort du nombre de
contamination eau covid-19 sur les
cartes diffusé par les médias américain
on s'aperçoit que ce sont
essentiellement les pays du nord-est des
États-Unis qui sont touchés par cette
augmentation par exemple l'État du
Massachusetts a connu une hausse de 70 %
du nombre de carreaux en l'espace de 2
semaines et à l'échelle nationale 7
augmentation se lève tout de même à 30 %
de quoi inquiéter les autorités
sanitaires américaine qui met une
nouvelle fois l'accent sur la
vaccination et notamment sur cette dose
de rappels qui est désormais ouverte au
16 17 ans à Joe Bayonne est revenu sur
cette campagne de vaccination est
particulièrement sur cette dose de
rappels écouter le
nous voyons de plus en plus d'Américains
le faire 50 million 50 million de
personnes ont maintenant reçu leur
injection de rappel et nous effectuons
se rappelle à un rythme record environ 1
million de personnes par jour et
l'Amérique fait des progrès 200 million
de personnes ont été vacciné et plus
d'enfants ont été vacciné que dans
n'importe quel autre pays du monde
toujours est-il que les États-Unis viens
de passer péniblement la barre des 60
pourcents de leur population pleinement
vacciné il faut aussi préciser que la
plupart des mesures d'obligation de
vaccination de la Maison-Blanche sont
suspendus par des décisions de tribunaux
américain alors Joe Bayonne la semaine
dernière à détailler la stratégie de la
Maison Blanche en ce qui concerne la
lutte contre la pandémie de covid-19 à
l'approche de la période hivernale
efface à l'émergence du baryon Omicron
il avait notamment annoncer le
durcissement des conditions d'accès pour
les voyageurs qui souhaite se rendre aux
États-Unis mais ça ne va rien donc
t'inquiète il a été détecté dans moins
22 États aux États-Unis alors la plupart
des patients sur lesquels a été détectée
ce variant au micro ne sais pas son nom
tout faire que de symptômes léger mais
la forte contagiosité qui lui est
attribué inquiète les autorités
américaines qui appelle toujours à la
vaccination au respect des gestes
barrière ainsi que le port du masque
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'a décidé à
gouverneur de l'État de New York dans
cet état le port du masque de nouveau
obligatoire pour tous dans tous les
établissements seulement du public en
intérieur